20 oder so also alle zwei stunden
hallo ich in meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen endlich mal wieder
zu einem minecraft guide minecraft facts
blablabla hartings pumps ich weiß gar
nicht in welcher folge wir sind weil die
letzte schon so lange her ist es war
jedenfalls mal wieder gewünscht worden
und ich habe ja bei facebook immer so
die umfrage funktion sehr sehr mag ich
ja bester satz zwei war ja da frage ich
dann immer was für videos ihr so haben
wollt täglich blabla und da habe ich
dann abstimmen lassen zwischen partys
folgen die rc immer täglich mehrere
kommen wegen dieser neuen regelung habe
ich da noch einiges gut haben dass ich
da täglich jetzt drei videos von bringen
kann
und da haben mir dann leute geschrieben
macht doch mal wieder hier
minecraft kleid das kommt auch relativ
gut an bei euch deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht ich mach das doch mal wieder und
ich würds angefangen direkt an mit der
sache dass er mir immer wieder effekt in
die kommentare schreiben könnt weil ich
die daraus hauptsächlich entnehmen aber
wird vielleicht nicht solche sachen wie
einst enthält 64 blöcke oder so das was
jeder weiß also schon so sachen die
jetzt eventuell noch nicht jeder weiß
und das ist heute eine sache die auch
nicht eventuell jeder wissen sollte
bleibt und zwar ozelot erhalten keinen
fall schaden
ja das war es schon und zwar ist das ja
allgemein so bei katzen ja okay wenn man
so aus 1000 metern als eine runter
schmeißt dann sterben sie sich schon
höchstwahrscheinlich aber katzen land
immer auf allen vier füße und die kann
man echt neuen schmeißen oder solange
auf allen klischees und verletzten sich
echt sehr sehr wenig deswegen ist es bei
mozart auch so ich kann es ihm passieren
und rücken die sich gegenseitig runter
und ihr seht schon wenn die hierunter
fallen die erhalten alle keinen fall
schaden da kommt man wenn man die stelle
erhalten die allerdings falsch ist klar
nur wenn die runterfallen erhalten
keinen fall schaden und können dann auch
einfach weiter so rumhüpfen ganz normal
also da passiert echt gar nix das war's
dann auch schon mit dem ersten effekt
und ich würde sagen nicht nur noch ein
paar toll das ist ein totales eigentor
gewählt so wichtig gleich alle wieder
umbringen muss oder wisst ihr seite vor
dabei wie bringe ich die denn jetzt wohl
speziell weg hier
das wird so freches
so weit geht nur kurz alle runter
tschüss möchte es ihr langsam und
qualvoll stirbt durch dieses an
ich mache aber ganz bisschen lauter in
okay jetzt kann nicht weil jetzt dort
dass er noch im moment herr okay jetzt
manchmal ganz kurz den ton lauter
na gut das was mit dem ersten vers mag
eigentlich katzen aber ich musste jetzt
irgendwo bringen alle greenpeace leute
oder tierschutzverbände hätten schon
längst auf den like -button gedrückt
aber als herrliche wenige cent oder
beleuchtung wir sehen uns sofort wieder
beim 2 und dann kommen wir auch direkt
schon zum zweiten fact und zwar haben
spinnennetze keinen einfluss auf höhen
spinnen beziehungsweise keinen effekt
ich hab mir so eine coole tolle arena
aufgebaut auf der pyramide wird insulin
drumrum attrappe freigegeben
so und zwar wenn ich jetzt einfach eine
höhen spinne drauf setzte bzw
das ist keine spinne hektisch ach ich
habe eine ganz normale spinne gehört man
da von spinne du also das warte ja ja
kommt so mich anzugreifen muss ich sie
ganz klein hierhin setzte er kann jetzt
gebe hier runter die fallende einfach
durch und die können dadurch laufen und
alles und blau
so kommt jetzt geht man durch so also
die steckt noch nicht fest wenn ich da
rein gehe und dadurch laufe dann hakt
das doch also ich kann da nicht so
durchlaufen
welche die kleinen spanne die können da
ganz einfach durchlaufen die sind jetzt
alle drin wenn ich euch das mal mit
einem anderen ort zeigen zum beispiel
mit einem brett
das bleibt er ganz einfach drin hängen
flutscht ganz ganz langsam weiter runter
lassen
und im gegensatz zu den höhlen spinde
sind ganz kleinen winterlich und die
kinder dann einfach durch diese
geräusche regen mich gerade ob das sind
ein paar viele die banken sich schon
mehr oder weniger aus antiken oder
raclette dann stimmt da muss ich dann
ein diamant schwert ankommen und da so
ein bisschen nachhelfen
jedenfalls haben die halt kein effekt
darauf das heißt sie können ganz einfach
durchlaufen die interessiert das gar
nicht dass da irgendwelche spinnenweben
sind oder nicht also die laufende recht
einfach durch ich habe jetzt noch ein
bisschen zu tun mit den ganzen sachen
ich will einfach mal sagen also wegen
kemna facetime ist nicht an weil ich
gerade geduscht und mich ich bin einfach
total cup und ich habe einfach keinen
bock das aufzubauen
aber ich finde sowas kann auch ohne
facebook machen dann muss man jetzt
nicht unbedingt reaktionen zeigen
ich meine ich quatsch er nur da werdet
ihr einfach mein gesicht gesehen wie ich
gequatsche von daher ich muss jetzt noch
ein bisschen töten und meine welche
zerstören und dann sehen uns jetzt beim
dritten weg wieder aha so kommen wir nun
zum dritten und zwar die ersten beiden
facts wie schon relativ viel aufwand
gekostet habe mit dem ganzen aufbauen
und jetzt auch den ganzen also dem dings
aufbauen
dann fällt zeigen und dann wieder die
welt aufbauen er ist der dritte feld
mehr oder weniger ein fun fact und zwar
wenn ihr kein zieht ein geht bei
minecraft da kann ich mal ganz kurz
rausgehen so neue welt erstellen kreativ
modus hier wir geben kein sieht eine
neue welt erstellen
und dann können wir einfach mal zieht
eingeben 49 31 16 45 blabla der benutzer
einfach die uhrzeit also bei mir ist es
gerade 16 uhr 24 und 26 sekunden
das heißt er diese uhrzeit einfach
glauben also dass sieht hier das ist
jetzt natürlich nicht die uhrzeit bei
mir grad nicht - 49 stunden nur blabla
er gibt halt diesen sieht der urzeit
dann einfach ein und dann kommt er hier
bei raus erkennt das bestimmt wenn ihr
zieht ein geht zum beispiel penis dann
ist er sieht penis allerdings
andererseits auch dieser code der hier
unten drin steht und bei mir ist der
sieht jetzt so halt meine urzeit und
rekorde hält er da unten drin steht und
das ist halt die uhrzeit mit
millisekunden alles ganz genau deswegen
gibt es nie die gleichen welten wenn ihr
einfach so auf generieren drückt außer
ihr drückt echt genau gleichzeitig drauf
und ja deswegen dass es auf jeden fall
schon so eine art fun fact und dann
würde ich sagen sehen wir uns jetzt beim
richtigen fun factor wieder
hey da sind wir beim fun fact und zwar
der normale fun fact diesmal also nicht
effect 3 sondern der normale fun fact
ist dass sich das wetter
alle sieben in game tage ändert also
circa alle zwei stunden also ein in game
tag dauert ca ich weiß nicht 15 minuten
glaube ich oder 20 oder so also alle
zwei stunden
ich weiß nicht was das schafft er hat
webber nennen wir es einfach dancing
show es tut mir leid tut man also das
wetter ändert sich alle sieben in game
tage ein in dem tag dauerte 20 minuten
also die sonne geht dann einfach unter
ihr seht dass die sonne bewegt sich die
sonne geht unter mode geht auf blabla
und alle sieben tage ändert sich das
wetter zu donner gewitter regen schnee
und was das auch immer ist diese wahl
hat diese komischen lila bach so das
internet gewesen
lasst mich den röcken greifen also das
ändert sich alle sieben in game tage das
war der fun fact das was auch wieder mit
minecraft fact minecraft drei fix plus
fun fact die ich euch immer unregelmäßig
präsentiere immer wenn ich zeit habe
klausurphase beginnt die garda nach
steyr starte ich richtig durch also ihr
bekommt jetzt richtig viele folgen mega
projekt erstmal das schaffe ich nebenbei
neben der klausurphase aber nach der
klausurphase geht's dann weiter mit
reduce icc blabla ihr könnt mir wieder
fest in die kommentare schreiben jetzt
euch gefallen hat wirklich meinen daumen
hoch freuen und dann durch die wolken
ist schauen wir uns mal die sonne
wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal